dieu existe il habite à bruxelles loi
2129 quand on plonge le corps dans la
baignoire
le téléphone sonne loi de 1818 la file
d'à côté avance toujours fidèle à ce que
tu fais aujourd'hui qu'on n'est même pas
kitamissa leur faire du mal du tout le
monde meurt ou n'importe qui ferait
mieux que toi pas perdu de temps
exactement ce moment je me sens si bien
faire quelque chose c'est ce qu'il a
fait avec elle a balancé les dalles de
sol il est encore impossible de savoir
s'il s'agit d'un canular ou si ces
fameuses date de décès se confirme
je vais chercher et je peux dire que
cette fois le patron je suis petite
fille des cheveux noirs
qu'allons-nous faire du reste de notre
vie est la question la plus fréquente
sur les réseaux sociaux
soixante deux ans à vivre 62e
[Musique]
il vous aime bien je peux première fois
qu'on trouve quelque chose d'aussi beau
et lui j'ai jeté ma gère pas comme ça
ici c'est passé au miracle dieu nous dit
m ton prochain comme toi même
le deuxième est dit ça j'ai jamais dit
ça mais l'autre là il est parti en
sucette
tout ce qu'il a réussi à faire c'est se
faire qu ils sont un centre comme jewett
il a des pouvoirs tombé comme un super
héros n'ont plus marqué pour moi
fais toi à l'aise de me voir quelque
chose super qui je suis et c'est pas que
je suis qu'est ce que c'est que ce
bordel j'ai déjà rempli
ou encore kanye west